[Música]
mobilidade humana desafios e
oportunidade eu vou contar pra vocês
aqui nesse momento eu era ea mudança de
quem eu sou hoje eu descobri que nesse
processo eu era metade humano disse borg
mas vamos contar a parte mais antiga da
minha pessoa que foi sobre a humanidade
começou mais ou menos a 5 milhões de
anos atrás ea gente teve algumas
transformações que eu vou contar aqui
nessa apresentação que mudaram o jeito
que a gente interagiu com o planeta está
o primeiro foi a era do gelo era do gelo
fez o homo sapiens se adaptar e se
dedicarem aos seus concorrentes teve que
lá brigar com o neandertal com o chrome
os
outras espécies aí e você já ouvir uma
frase chama dá um pequeno passo para o
homem um grande passo para a humanidade
aí falaram quando o homem chegou à lua
mas eu acho que muito dessa frase pode
ser aplicada para essa própria evolução
do homem
foi quando a gente deu o primeiro passo
é conseguir ficar em pé
a partir daquele momento a gente
conseguiu enxergar mais longe ver as
oportunidades no nosso horizonte tanto
de comida e se proteger das ameaças
só que teve um outro acontecimento muito
importante pra gente
foi quando o nosso processador interno
teve uma mutação e alterou a maneira que
a gente conseguia gerir as informações
nosso cérebro passou de 200 centímetros
cúbicos pramil 420 mil escudos
só que essa máquina ela vinha com alguns
é alguns particulares ela consumia 25
por cento do nosso da nossa energia do
nosso corpo enquanto os nossos
concorrentes dos outros animais tinham
cérebro consumir apenas oito centímetros
8 é o centro da energia do corpo
e essa revolução cognitiva que aconteceu
quase 70
anos atrás ela gerou mais troca de
informações através de mais gestos mais
barulho o que conseqüentemente gerou uma
maior capacidade de proteção de
socialização
a nossa busca por comida ficou mais
fácil ea nossa produção também sofreu as
conseqüências
a partir disso a gente precisou mudar a
maneira como a gente se alimentava e aí
a gente chega na revolução agrícola o
que aconteceu mais ou menos oito mil
anos atrás e desceu um homem começou a
semear trigo domésticas os animais
consolidará aquele estilo de vida de
agricultor ou seja sedentário e aí que a
gente começa a ver como que a mobilidade
humana se transformou durante todo esse
tempo que a gente está na terra a vida
de agricultor tinha prós e contras as
contas mais estresse mais trabalho o que
acabou gerando uma hierarquia social e e
consequência disso um homem ele mudou a
natureza de nômades para acidentar ou
seja o homem virou o território a lista
ele ficou quase imóvel gerou um boom
populacional a gente perto ali das
fêmeas começamos a gostar do assunto
então a gente já produziu uma velocidade
muito grande e aí o próximo ponto que eu
acho que se destaca nessa história a
revolução científica como rené descartes
falou
penso logo existo então a partir de um
homem do momento que o homem entender o
que ele sabia quase nada ele começou a
usar o método científico para entender
realmente o que ele não entende o que
ele entendia a revolução gerou uma menor
distância no mundo
a gente começou a navegar pelos mares a
descoberta da américa
na verdade num mundo ainda menor a
velocidade das informações começou a a
circular com muita velocidade
naquele momento a gente tinha um mil e
quinhentos 11 pib mundial de 250 bilhões
de dólares
hoje em dia a gente está falando de uma
riqueza mundial em torno de 60 milhões
de dólares
a população passou dos seus 500 milhões
de humanos para quase 7 bilhões ea
necessidade do consumo de calorias do
ser humano como um todo passou de 13
trilhões de calorias para mais de 1500
bilhões de calorias
tudo isso aí gerou vários benefícios
último passagem dessa história ea parte
que eu virei cyborg acontecer agora em
2008 quando os times jobs lançou um
produto chamado iphone o iphone eu vejo
nessa história como se fosse uma outra
mutação do nosso cérebro aquela que
passou de 200 centímetros cúbicos para
1.400 centímetros cúbicos por que a
partir daquele momento a gente conseguiu
processar muito mais rápido às
informações armazenar uma quantidade
enorme de dados ea gente pode usar nossa
memória seletiva para coisas muito mais
importantes da internet nesse momento
acelerou os processos essenciais pra
gente continuar dominando esse planeta
como espécie
eu vejo o mercado financeiro que é a
minha praia como agricultura dos tempos
antigos onde a gente consegue otimizar a
aplicação dos recursos da maneira mais
eficaz
então a nova economia que surgiu disso
ela vem baseada no conceito de
compartilhamento ou seja é preciso mais
ter uma casa em angra e alugar por um
final de semana
eu não preciso mais ter um carro do ano
eu posso ligar pro uber pedir uma
categoria que vai me entregar carro do
ano
eu também não preciso mais ter a melhor
o dinheiro do mundo trabalhando só pra
mim porque eu consigo botar qualquer
restaurante através do food na porta da
minha casa
essa nova economia ao meu ver libera o
homem da escravidão da terra que ele
encontrou na revolução agrícola porque
agora ele pode viajar o mundo e que
controla o seu destino
e no meio dessa economia compartilhada
onde os apps
no seu celular tem uma coisa que a
central ea o conteúdo e conteúdo hoje em
dia é poder
e aí que eu me insiro nessa situação
porque você pode ter o recurso que você
quiser
na hora que você fizer na palma da sua
mão e agora tá um pouco de como eu tenho
de ser um caseiro adoro ficar em casa
ficar com a minha família ficar debaixo
das cobertas com minha mulher vendo
netflix mais uma vez aí um exemplo de
como a gente tem acesso agora biblioteca
infinita de conteúdo e comecei a
entender que as pessoas não estavam mais
querendo me ouvir sobre investimentos no
meu círculo a linha íntimo meu amigo
estava de saco cheio de escutar o tio
lhe falando toda hora de bolsa de
valores de ações de mercado financeiro
a idéia de começar a falar disso na
internet ou seja mais uma vez
possibilitando que o trecho a minha vida
ea vida dos outros através do conteúdo
financeiro que é uma coisa que as
pessoas têm muita distância cria uma
certa dificuldade
tudo mudou basicamente um ano atrás
no último revelou in último dia das
bruxas eu fui para nova york e abri meu
primeiro produto digital
eu pensei assim pô onde é que um centro
do mundo financeiro
nova iorque fui para nova iorque subir
lá no maior prédio que eu podia e lado
em paz tentam faria assim gente tá
aberto aqui a minha teoria do tingüí
online e as pessoas começaram a entender
de finanças numa linguagem muito mais
clara porque o tite foi no colo ele está
sempre do meu lado sempre com paciência
para escutar e pela prime surpresa de
verdade
naquele dia eu fechei 30 mentores ou
seja tinha uma demanda enorme me
esperando
eu percebi que aquele fato de levar o
mundo para as pessoas
engajada muito conteúdo não bastava só
eu falar de finanças
eu tinha que viajar o mundo mostrar para
as pessoas outros lugares para criar uma
distração ali e desde então
usar gravata mais três vezes para a
europa mas cinco vezes no total e no
último ano eu fiz nove viagens
internacionais para mostrar o mundo
financeiro do mundo físico para as
pessoas que me seguem e elas não
precisam mais sair da sua casa para
conhecer a a califórnia à sede de
empresas como a apple a os maiores
bancos de wall street e também as
maravilhas do mundo moderno do mundo
antigo da europa
tudo isso eu posso mostrar para as
pessoas através do meu celular e aí elas
ganharam de novo a capacidade de se
mover no mundo mas dentro de casa
e muito desse processo que eu divido nas
redes sociais têm basicamente três
gatinhos mentais que são técnicos para
você chamar a atenção das pessoas que é
o seguinte primeiro reciprocidade
por incrível que pareça quanto mais eu
dou mais as pessoas querem comprar de
mim ou seja você tem que dar o primeiro
passo para sair da inércia e para as
pessoas que você está a fim de fazer uma
troca troca da atenção dela no meu caso
pelo meu conteúdo
a segunda coisa que eu gosto muito é a
prova social que aprova social gente não
adianta nada eu ficar falando de mercado
financeiro e não investir realmente em
outra prova social que eu tinha o
seguinte eu tinha que mostrar para as
pessoas que eu poderia ganhar
saí de casa porque quando comecei a
ajudar sobre marketing digital eu vi que
uma das maiores necessidades das pessoas
não era ficar em casa para poder viajar
a hora que quiser mas sim poder ver os
filhos crescerem
eu não sou pai mas eu vejo que o dó que
dá no coração dos meus bons
ao terem que sair 7 6 da manhã para
trabalhar às vezes só voltam às nove da
noite ou seja o marketing digital ele
reforçou esse comportamento que eu
gostava quero ter liberdade na minha
mobilidade ou seja eu posso estar aqui
agora em bambu fazendo o conteúdo
gravado pelas redes sociais
eu posso fazer isso de casa quanto
quiser mas também se eu quiser mostrar o
mundo
pra mim a audiência eu tenho total
liberdade ou seja o mundo agora ele gira
em torno do nosso centro aqui que é a
rede social
graham o youtube tem várias ferramentas
para isso e por fim a terceira terceiro
gatilho mentawaii é a autoridade
autoridade ela mostra que você não está
ali pra brincar que você não é um
aventureiro e pra isso você precisa se
dedicar de maneira intensa e quase que
dedicada exclusivamente para um assunto
graças a deus eu consigo conciliar o
mercado financeiro com martin ditar
porque no final das contas eu só tenho
que documentar a minha realidade e tudo
e fornece caminho para que eu tenha
outros canais para distribuir conteúdo
pode parecer muito simples esse negócio
mas de conseguir fazer um faturamento
milhão de dólares 10 uma empresa de uma
pessoa fez com que a minha cabeça saísse
daquele sedentarismo tal que eu me
encontrava antes da mobilidade
totalmente é avançada em relação ao
mostrar pro mundo pessoas que o mundo
menor do que a gente imagina
mas também ele é muito mais diverso do
que a gente imagina
eu já fui na islã mostrar as geleiras já
foi no deserto de israel mostrar como
que a a cidade de pedra ainda existe
nesse mundo tecnológico e no final das
contas eu quero sem terminar dentro do
fone passando meu conteúdo porque não
importa aonde eu estou mas sim o que eu
estou passando pra vocês e este aqui é a
parte board falando ao bec obrigado
gente
[Aplausos]
[Música]